previously on TV since boy you really
got me up against the wall this time
Jerry look I'm fine with the speed at
which Rick made this smart dog helmet
but he must have already had this thing
built except for like one screw to
simply go to his garage and use a drill
for two seconds and produce a finished
product go to the bathroom
not sure how impressive that is be
clearly just flushed the toilet because
he didn't have time to climb on top of
it and actually use it geez Rick and the
time it took you to make this thing
couldn't you just you know helped me
with my homework more tea would be
amazing a TV since I mean the guy
teaches high school method taken for an
active treatment I see someone hasn't
seen Stand and Deliver that's on you
Rick Somers phone shows snuffles very
close to Jerry but he somehow ends up
two feet away from him when it cuts to
the next shot oh yeah this should play
out just fine
you said the same thing equally
sarcastically at our wedding and guess
what is it just me or is the Jerry and
Beth marriage way sadder than it is
funny
also sitcom husband constantly does and
says stupid things sitcom wife gets
irritated with them to the point where
no one understands how they would have
ever gotten married in the first place
and had kids but somehow they make it
work just barely cliche negotiate with
you because we're both rational adults
that don't want anything bad to happen
and because I have a human shield
how was Rick able to human shield mrs.
pancakes since she was clearly behind
mr. goldenfold when all this started
this absurd and funny I think Morty's
ability to know exactly what goldenfold
did and give a full report of it is what
selfish I'll just go ask her to talk on
the phone not to kill us when she wakes
up whoa whoa Morty the trick to
incepting is making people think they
came up with the idea oh really then
what was that on the airplane then when
you pretended you were going to blow it
up how was that top notch incepting Rick
looks like goldenfold has some
predilections so shameful he buries them
in the dreams of the people and his
dreams
I don't think goldenfold is nearly that
shameless about his fantasies remember
the first episode that guy was just
standing there while Morty unconsciously
grabbed his boobs and he leaned into it
at school
illegally safe knockoffs of an 80s
horror character with miniature swords
for fingers instead of nice why would he
need to be legally safer it why would he
need to be legally safe
okay fine goddamnit the show is clever
and funny and all the things they send
off it was only with years of selective
breeding and genetic altering that this
Noble Beast was transformed into man
subservient little buddy
convenient TVs position is convenient my
testicle cemre
first off why is snuffles terrorizing
summer of all people over this second
off as a supergenius dog you damn well
know where your testicles went buddy you
shall now call me snowball because my
fur is pretty and white snowball must
have gotten this idea when researching
video clips about David Duke let's go
where the possess a soul the whole time
do you mean the snuffles snowball meant
to go in and chastise summer over things
she wasn't responsible for hope her
parents would wake up and go into a room
to see what the matter was then
dramatically revealed this other dog
when the time was right for me to get an
A in math so how is Rick planning on
getting more TAS and all of his other
classes he's just going to Inception
every one of Morty's teachers every year
school inception marathon inception
thong he keeps saying we can run but we
can't hide like if the truth was that we
could hide it's not like he'd be sharing
that information with us you know this
is a hilarious Rick and Morty discussion
about a troupe in horror movies that
characters never really think about but
I'm wondering why they can hide when
scary terry has been popping out of
nowhere throughout this inception dream
sequence in places where he shouldn't
know where they are
hi honey you're home early how was your
day I have a lot of questions about this
little life that's occurring in a dream
inside a dream inside a dream inside a
dream but mainly these murderers use
hand soap my back rich and septic abuse
I love you too Terry why is this boner
look Wow my sin hat wants to question
everything about what's in this room
right now this domestic scene for scary
Terry and the claw marks that are
everywhere that suggests a sex life that
is better than yours or mine deserves to
cinahl for detail and hilarity this must
be a dream because we just saw this
teacher push open a door with a doorknob
on it makes sense because he ain't turn
in that door knob don't even trip about
your pants dog here's a pair on us full
and where exactly did more to get the
pants from because I can buy many things
that happen in this episode but more to
getting bright enough to know how to
mediate the dream within a dream world
is not one of them these halves don't
belong to
[ __ ] that's interest this is the
coaster document right yes so I know
they're making fun of inception in this
episode but even while they're making
fun of it Rick was adhering to
inceptions rules about making it seem
like the person came up with the idea on
their own so I don't know how the scary
Terry rocket suddenly puts the idea of
giving Morty better grades into mr.
goldenfold's head that makes him think
he came up with it I'm entertained mind
you but this seems to be going against
the rules of even an inception spoof
know one thing for sure
I'm giving Morty an A in math that's
great but what is the weapon mr.
goldenfold shirts it's all he had was a
bowl of wheat that's they just couldn't
do this thing without a dogs playing
poker reference good thing well at least
I didn't really crap my pants
no no that happened before you went to
sleep Morty you're sleeping in your crap
right now wait was that even something
that happened I don't remember morty
saying he crapped his pants at any time
in this episode until now like it's
something that we were supposed to be
aware of already sounds like he just
wanted to wallow in a little bit joe
it's pretty bad in paris no ball we're
gonna need to do another operation
if snowball snuffles is so smart then
clearly he would know this is Rick
behind the dog mask I see dogs walking
out of an animal shelter into a war to
some other dimension but is this
supposed to be all dogs or just the ones
in Rick and Morty's town also this puts
the onus on the series to never show
dogs in this world ever again
there's some subconscious you've got a
new cop she's a real charmer I love you
oh my god he's trying to tell us
something that is so awesome
[Music]
sexual hang-ups in the pleasure chamber
are punishable by death you will walk
when it is time to walk you've got that
to Megan I'll come back tomorrow man
they'll be gone by then you'd better get
out of here before somebody sees us
introducing smart dogs the first dogs
trained to train humans mr. Spicoli
you're on dangerous ground here you are
causing a major disturbance on my time